[Music]
then kill for the thrill news video
submitted by Canada lone JK news Thank
You a thank you maple somebody has to
show me some bomb-ass poutine I want to
try buddy I really do cuz I do
I've had one [ __ ] you want food yeah
really though this is absolutely true
I had poutine and I wasn't that amazed
by it from someone like the best spots
however I've had like different versions
of poutine that people had over here and
it was better my probably like his
poutine consider street food maybe need
the street versions maybe man cuz his
cheese curds melted over with gravy and
fries it was a little too salty for me
and there wasn't anything to break it up
from we got this like Chief Kurt pizza
and Canada that was really [ __ ] good
oh yeah
two housemates who conspired to commit a
bucket-list murder together are now in
prison for life tie now that could be
cellmates a bucket-list murderer
as a person who watches a lot of true
crime shows I'm very interested in this
you know what people say like you should
be around people who are like-minded
this is not what we is about Trudy
Lennon who was 44 years old and Gemma
lily who is who's 26 oh what that they
were in a submissive dominant
relationship with each other was it Paul
even master yeah with like a
double-sided dildo they both choke each
other out at the same time yep type it's
like when they wake it's like you wear
those like latex masks and it's just the
mouth yeah Oh [ __ ] Michaels closet
yeah so Gemma the 26 year old this [ __ ]
she [ __ ] psycho soulless eyes she is
that Benjamin Franklin on the right
[Laughter]
Benjamin Franklin please I beg you uh so
funny yeah so true here aka Benjamin oh
good old Benny the mother of electricity
she has two kids one of them I don't
know the age of the other one but one of
her kids ages 14 years it seems Ben
Franklin she had like insane fantasies
to want to kill someone why is she so
mean she wanted to do it before she
turned 25 I get it it's kind of like the
end of the [ __ ] world remember that
series yeah kid yeah so they've been
killing animals that she's like time for
a human
so Gemma the crazy-ass she apparently
was she was a teenager she wrote some
some story about this serial killer and
the killer's name was SOS so she went by
SOS okay that is the number one sign
okay so I I love true crime [ __ ] and I
like read it's like about this all the
time or watch shows the number one sign
of the somebody committing crimes later
is they've journal about it or they
literally will write a whole story or
play about killing somebody I know that
there was like some kid did a school
shooting two years earlier he had
written a story about two guys that shot
up their school I know like the Menendez
brothers they wrote a play about killing
about two teenagers killing their
parents it's like yeah when they write
this [ __ ] Jalen Jalen okay I believe it
because people tell you like when you
want a better life and all that stuff
you're supposed to vision that you're
supposed to believe certain things like
like I told myself at one time I was
making only $1,000 a month and I said
I'm gonna make 20 grand a month I'm
gonna just do it and then once I
visualized it I created the map it will
happen and they say that a lot in likes
like like what do you call it in mine
state like psychology law of attraction
right well it also takes work that's
that's the part that I think a lot of
people they just wish wish
but they don't [ __ ] do the wars like
99% of the be right but here's the thing
it's because when you commit to writing
about something and then it's always on
your mind what happens is your mind
thinks that it's a priority so you're
constantly actively trying to achieve
what's on your head like whatever you're
thinking about so it's it could be that
these kids wrote about it they
visualized it they played maybe the
character yeah and then now their head
is like trying to fill the void of like
I got a play out what's happening here
hmm they probably enjoyed writing it so
much and they start to like when you're
writing it you go off into this fantasy
world and then because you're like
writing about such a crazy thing and
you're writing about so heartlessly you
desensitize yourself to it in real life
so that's why some people are actually
like yeah I don't know that's just nutty
that [ __ ] is crazy
I wonder if Stephen King really like has
a lot of dead people under his house
yeah did they say if she was the
dominant or the submissive one of their
relationship engine that I want to know
it seems actually was because it seems
like she was the one that actually did
the killing so they hatched a plan to
have to get a vulnerable victim and so
they decided to go with Trudy's
fourteen-year-old son
friend named Aaron who had Asperger's
syndrome who don't know what is
Asperger's okay it's a developmental
disorder characterized by significant
difficulties of social interaction they
take things very literally nonverbal
communication they say funny stuff
though we have a friend whose brother
has Asperger's and then every time he
gets in his fight it gets in a fight
with his wife and from the family he
calls her a come Guster come Gosselin
[ __ ] yeah Asperger's just sounds like
hamburgers are coming out and if you ask
them like hey what's up you actually
like nothing this guy I do that to you
that it's like that one's guy from
guardians of the galaxy the rock guy
yeah I call him that
Batista Rock no he's not but I think for
him it looks like a Roger
alright so yeah he looks like a lava
what is his name now cuz I call you the
Drex there you axe
yeah that's Drax I don't mind being
dragged his no tracks he's funny he's
the one that made the movie he says
funny ass lines
yep yeah so they lured Aaron - I know I
said it were they Lord Lord him Lord O
Lord Lord Lord Lord Lord
they lauded Aaron this was Aaron by the
way how old is he 18 well that makes
sense
he has developmental issues so his
maturity yeah a joke yeah yeah 14 year
olds so they told him that they needed
him to help them with fixing computers
and so they told them to go meet up at
this duh she was about to fix their
[ __ ] computer Dan was about to do a
favor for them right that's like
inviting someone to like cook food for
you and then you kill them wait did he
die he died oh [ __ ] what are they okay
with me honey they stabbed him to death
and they also use the wire to choke it
like she him as he was trying to fix the
computer
they killed Trudy in the worst ways
possible she choked him so hard that the
wire broke and then like stabbed him
yeah here's a more [ __ ] up Twitter
hurts my heart
what they did was did they just remember
him I don't think so but what they did
is they buried him in the backyard and
had the Sun Trudi Sun helped tile up
this area and not knowing what was that
oh my god [ __ ] I mean obviously
everything else is twisted but that's
just another level of [ __ ] so how do
they find that um and then this is what
I look like after
what would after what is that the same
area commonly child oh the worst thing
you can do after you kill somebody this
one I watched a lot of Forensic Files is
put in a new wall a new floor new tile
like if somebody goes missing when cops
go in your backyard if they see freshly
tilled soil dig that [ __ ] up
brand new tiles dig that [ __ ] up now
you're just telling people how to not
get caught don't do that these shows out
there oh yeah
yeah they're like we're literally from
you got a murder song I don't think she
watched it because they did it oh don't
you gotta murder somebody how all you
got to do you got to get a small patient
[ __ ] his ass up yeah oh now Asian uh
somebody else somebody really talk to
them because you know it's easy to bury
somebody smaller in somebody's real lead
or you could take an axe to the spine
and just fall that person oh my god
that's why I stay busy because obviously
that's a really good idea yeah like just
slip the discount of any stories that
you want to share with that I just watch
a lot of TV don't write anything can
they give her the electric chair like
breezing them backwards like tired limbs
too [ __ ] horses and make the horses
run off yeah what the [ __ ] so I wanted
they need to do something horrendous to
her I don't know yes yes all right so
the crazy psycho [ __ ] she was just so
like who's [ __ ] coming from it yeah
so she ended up going to work the next
day and told everybody told everyone in
great detail and then later oh yeah like
that's that's something that I just I
read her around
where did she do this like where does
she take place she looks like she's a
Walmart kind of girl she's a man
the supermarket mm a night manager so
she would be graveyard yeah she would be
a night manager real yes why today you
know what I did the other day I want to
show you guys how it's [ __ ] twisted
these people are so there's pictures of
the body so we're done do want to be
blue or white okay okay so Trudy is
saying seriously how have you been able
to wait this long to take your first I
want to see this start now you have
amazing willpower the intense feelings
that build up everyday and the need to
release them is so strong in me I can
only imagine just how much more intense
they are for you dan I've had many very
close calls your strength amazes me I
feel as though I cannot rest until the
blood of a fresh screaming pleading
victim is gushing out and pulling on the
floor until all the roads and streets
are stained red and abandoned and the
fear in the back of everyone's minds and
on the tongues of each human left
standing is SOS I cannot shift this
belief some of the Shakespeare play has
become not only ready for me but that it
means me to be ready it's definitely
time I am ready you are ready you know
what's so annoying about this I'm not
even like creeped out she trying way too
yeah bro Shakespeare I want you to come
here she wants to play that role of
badass so bad yeah but y'all just ruined
it holder's during the trial that were
saying that Trudy so first of all they
were both blaming each other saying like
it wasn't me it was this crazy-ass
[ __ ] idea I didn't do anything
Trudy was saying that those text
conversations she just thought it was
roleplay with Gemma like she didn't know
that it was gonna be something real
supposedly so that's why it's all
overdramatic supposedly is role-playing
[ __ ] Oh today we're gonna play role
play somebody died with a [ __ ]
play so hooked on it yeah you know based
off of Emma it's like prosecutors are
saying that it was like gemma actually
did the dirty work
that's my Franklin no no the other one
26 year old ask crazy [ __ ]
she was just hanging out of watching
helping I get the vibe though like
because of all the weird crime [ __ ] that
I've done the gym with the one who do me
the crime watch know of all the weird
crime [ __ ] that I watched the vibe that
I get from that was this is a woman that
felt it's very powerless for her whole
life she felt very very obviously which
would explain why she was the dominant
one in the lesbian relationship she's a
manager and she she wants people to be
afraid of her that's why she told me
exactly right yeah she wants people to
be scared of her comeback yeah she
that's what she wants she was she's
somebody that feels powerless and she
felt very weak as a child so this is her
way of thinking she takes her power back
you're just very twisted and it's sad
because she's actually Loki a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's like you know CEOs that
love to play submissive and slave and
stuff like that because they have so
much [ __ ] power that they need to
feel dominated they need to be whipped
and told what to do and stuff I heard
that that's like a extreme compensation
for that yeah so the reason why they got
nailed for the crime was because they
found the police they found security
footage of these two women at a store
buying large amounts of hydro
hydrochloric acid Oh
they also found security footage of them
meeting up with Aaron at the parking lot
where they of the morning of his death
and the fact that they found the body on
their property was just I mean the body
on the property I think that's what did
it in the most time
[Laughter]
like they dig up the body in their
backyard and they're like who do you
think did this you looking at the body
the like I don't know if he's dead or
not so they each got sentenced to a
minimum of 28 years each so and then
already they've already had a very bad
time in prison because Trudy has gotten
a boiling pot of water dumped over her
another holy [ __ ] kept in like
protective custody because people want
to attack her
yes oh my god like being in jail is some
scary [ __ ] last oh damn so that means
the other inmates are like something's
wrong with you yeah so they were down
because I would think like a serial
killer it would just be super respected
in jail or something but a date these
are two [ __ ] that killed a kid with
like they could see right through it
yeah the problems like grabbing a [ __ ]
rat and stopping you [ __ ] okay like you
wanted to feel big and strong well here
you are now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]